joining us now to discuss it retired
acting ice director and
fox news contributor tom homan tom
thanks for taking time on saturday let's
get right to what you heard
from bill down there in del rio about
ice 30 of detainees refusing to take it
1200
positive yeah they got 1200 in custody
right now they're positive but griff
they've had over 7 500
positive cases run through the ice
program and this is who i should get in
custody of
most of these people coming across the
southern border are not coming to ice
custody as you showed earlier
they're going to bus stations they're
being released over the country at a
time when this country is talking about
re-masking
and like in la then they're talking
about door-to-door vaccination checks
they want to hold americans
accountable to this covenant and mean
and meanwhile with the northern border
still shut down over covet
the southern border is wide open to
covet over 20 cbp officers have died
from covid
because we put them on the front line
this administration to deal with kobe to
come across that border every day
and this administration doesn't care tom
let me
put up on the screen the stats in the
rgv
sector up 900 percent in positive
coveted
cases among detainees migrants crossing
135
in just the first two weeks the chief
there brian hastings says
he currently has 44 agents right now
that are positive five of which are in
the hospital at this moment but
as you are fully well aware these are
the folks that have been
detained we don't know about the ones
that entered
that were not apprehended so the problem
perhaps
more pervasive well it's a lot it's a
lot more uh pervasive
gareth because the border shows already
said approximately 1500 a day
escape apprehension who are those folks
these aren't folks
family groups and children want to turn
themselves to the border patrol these
are people that don't want a big car
why because they're criminals they're
they're drug traffickers they're
trafficking in women and children
these are people that don't want to get
caught because they know if they get
caught because of who they are they will
be detained
so when you think about fifteen hundred
days already three hundred thousand got
aways approximately
three hundred thousand got away since
biden became president
who are they where are they are they
would be terrorists are they criminals
are there drug traffickers
we don't know that should scare the hell
out of every american and we're getting
some of the criminals
in fact in the rgb sector more than 600
criminal migrants have been apprehended
this fiscal year in just the last 48
hours
we can show you three ms-13
gang members known gang members we know
that
because they self-identify many
committing crimes in the u.s coming back
across the border is it your sense tom
that the threat
of criminal migrants is growing right
now
absolutely because they know the
border's open they know that 40
4 out of 10 borderlands are no longer on
the line because they're dealing with
humanitarian crisis
so they're they're taking a risk and
making entry so if they caught that
money griff
how many didn't they catch the how many
that 300 000 you know where criminals
got away and look
and criminals and gang members also
embed themselves into this
as a child as a part of a family unit
because
we did operation matador when i was life
director we did operation matador
in new york city and long island we
arrested 475 gang members mostly ms-13
and guess what 42 percent of them
42 percent enter this country as an
unaccompanied alien child
or family group so it's just not who
we're aware of it's just not who gets
away
it's about these family groups uac
they're not what they
always people always think they are many
more gang members and criminals
and 42 percent of gang members is a high
number
and they'll bend themselves in these
groups to get released tom this week in
a town hall president biden addressing
the situation at the border here's what
he had to say
there were thousands of people in in
in custody with the border patrol it's
now cut by
90 percent where there is considerably
down
considerably down do you agree
well congratulations president biden
you're getting real good at releasing
people quickly
that is what they're doing yeah they're
less in border patrol custody because
you release them quicker
taking a bus station put them on
airplanes send them all the country so
congratulations on that you're releasing
people
quickly you think that's a success i'll
tell you what it is
it's an enticement for more people to
come to the border illegally because
they know they're not being detained
they know the government u.s government
under president biden will buy them a
plane ticket
we'll get them a bus ticket to get him
to their final destination
this administration is complicit in the
illegal activity on the border and any
smuggling
why are they doing this because it's
open borders it is open borders they
don't care about the crime they don't
care about
the covet this is an open borders agenda
president biden sold himself out
to the progressive left to win this
election and the progressive left is
running the government they're in the
they're running congress
they're at the department of homeland
security they're at the white house and
their agendas
open these borders up regardless of
regardless of the crime the covid
90 000 uh fentanyl overdose deaths
already this year
90 of those drugs come across the open
southwest port according to dea
it's a shame it's disgusting the drugs a
whole nether part of this
crisis tom homan thanks for taking time
today on saturday keep us posted sir
thanks for firing me up